الاستخفاف الروسي بدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه خلال الاشهر الاولى من الحرب
تحول مؤخرا الى ارتباك وحيره حول قوتها
فرغم اشتداد كثافه الهجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه في الفتره الاخيره الا ان
اوكرانيا اكدت ان هذه الهجمات لم تصب
اهدافها اما السر في تحول الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه الى قوه حصينه غير قابله
للاختراق فيكمن بطبيعه الحال بمزيج من
الاسلحه الغربيه وبمقدمتها الامريكيه كما
تقول شبكه سي ان ان نجاح قوه الرضعه
الاوكرانيه يعود اولا لنشر منظومه باتريوت
الامريكيه خاصه في منطقه العاصمه كييف
انظمه قادره على ضرب الطائرات على
ارتفاعات عاليه ومتوسطه حتى كما حقق
النظام الامريكي نيسانس حيث نجح وصلت الى
100% وفقا لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
الخزانات الاوكرانيه اذا عجت كذلك بصواريخ
كروز وبعض الصواريخ الباليسيه وصواريخ
الدفاع الجوي قصيره ومت وسطه المدى كانت
قدمتها دول النيتو الاخرى كبطاريات
الالمانيه ايرستيل هذا المزيج اذا ساهمت
فيه اسلحه تمتلكها اوكرانيا اصلا من
الحقبه السوفيتيه ونجحت بنسبه 80% في صد
الهجمات ومنها صواريخ اس 300
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات